[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity president Trump versus the
oblivious left she's back and despite
being urged to get out of the public
spotlight by politicians and pundits on
both sides of the aisle oblivious
Hillary Clinton just won't go away
after facing heavy criticism for her
demeaning remarks about Trump voters
while in Asia the twice failed
presidential candidate is once again
lashing out during a paid speech at
Rutgers University
Clinton complained that the recent
criticism lodged against her is because
she's a woman take a look people saying
get off the public stage and shut up
which is something we're hearing all the
time yeah how do you well I you know
that that began to happen after the
election and you know the election was
pretty traumatic
I was really struck by how people said
that to me you know mostly people in the
press for whatever reason like oh you
know go away go away and I had a one of
the young people works for me go back
and do a bit of research they never said
that to any man who was not elected but
I do worry that what's happened to the
Republican Party is that it's being held
captive by a very small group of
powerful forces we have seen the power
of the NRA for example while Hillary
Clinton continues to bash Republicans
and play the gender card her speaking
fees are taking a hit according to
reports the $25,000 Hillary Clinton
received for the speech you just saw was
actually 7,000 dollars less than Rutgers
paid Jersey Shore reality TV star Snooki
so joining us now with reaction to our
NC chairwoman Rhonda McDaniel Rana I
just want to say one thing
Hillary Clinton just said in that sound
she said that the press kept telling her
to go away now what I find shocking is
they told her anything given that she
roped them off do you remember that
during the campaign she had them all
roped off so she wouldn't have to talk
to them what's your take on Hillary and
what she's doing in the public square
well where do we start I mean she's so
willing to play the sexist card when in
reality she is being treated exactly
like any other nominee who would have
continued to denigrate half of the
country who would continue to fail to
acknowledge the failings of their
campaign and the other thing she doesn't
acknowledge is what President Trump
provided for the American people which
was a vision of more jobs and higher
wages and so by continually refusing to
acknowledge the failings of of her
campaign and why she lost she is hurting
her party and her party is saying please
go away you are hurting us no other
previous nominee has put their foot in
their mouths as much as Hillary Clinton
has since this election ended and you
know what what's interesting is we never
thought that that Clinton machine would
ever be confronted by someone as dead
as some of these politicians to say you
know maybe it's time for you to go away
or as I say to go back into the woods
but Rana you know the talk about the the
midterms in a presidential election
being a you know first term I should say
it it's usually it benefits the other
party but now with Hillary Clinton and
this lunacy her saying that the election
was traumatic you know doesn't this
benefit Republicans it does and I do
think the people who aren't telling her
to go away are the Democrat leadership
but we haven't heard from Chuck Schumer
and Nancy Pelosi and what she said was
truly insulting to say that women only
voted for President Trump because our
husbands told us too that is so
denigrating to say that we are against
african-americans having jobs and and
and and progressing in our economy that
is so insulting and so what she has said
should be denounced by Chuck Schumer and
Nancy Pelosi and these red state
Democrats that we're not hearing from
joe donnelly debbie Stabenow in my state
Tammy Baldwin bill Nelson where are you
so it's interesting that the Democrat
leadership is not distancing themselves
as vocally as they should be from the
very very insulting comments of Hillary
Clinton and it is going to help us in
these midterms because President Trump
not only put forward a vision in this
election he is delivering with people
getting bigger paychecks and more jobs
coming back people are feeling so good
about their lives they have more money
to spend on their families this is
something that they're going to take to
the polls in November and say I need to
return Republicans to office because
they are delivering for me and my family
well and you know what it's not just
returning Republicans to office but
those Republicans who are like-minded
like the president Trump you know I
think that going forward it's only going
to benefit candidates to at least talk
the way President Trump does yeah of
course I mean look at what President
Trump has done in this year Isis is on
the run our military is being funded he
cares about our borders and our laws he
cares about our judges making sure they
abide by our Constitution and then just
look at the deregulation and the
cuts 2/3 of Americans are seeing bigger
paychecks because of President Trump so
every Republicans should be looking at
what President Trump did he is a bold
leader and it is going to take a bold
vision to win in these midterms and
we're gonna need to get out there and
make our case we're starting to see
those numbers close the RNC's raise
double the DNC we are in in all these
battleground states we know we have to
keep these majorities because we have
something to fight for America is on the
comeback and we cannot go back to the
Schumer Pelosi Dark Ages right Ronna
thank you so much for being with us
thanks for having me